not everyone is going to be staying
alive if the squad has anything to say
about it they are at it again some in
the merry band of progressive lawmakers
think it is racist for Congress to take
on China the house voted overwhelmingly
to establish a select committee
challenging the Communist Chinese on
things like trade defense foreign policy
and human rights 146 Democrats joined
Republicans in backing the measure but
Ayanna Presley thinks it's a terrible
idea
it's really clear that this is just a
committee that would further embolden
anti-asian rhetoric and hate and put
lives at risk so do you think the 146
Democrats who voted yes on it are wrong
in their votes
we just see it differently
all right interesting you know who might
see it the same way she does uh the
Chinese Communist Party those would be
talking points that they would offer in
order to create a little bit of a
firestorm in the U.S absolutely but I
you know I don't mind any opposition you
know it but not one that's based on a
lie right anti-asian hate believe it or
not is not driven by these geopolitical
moves I don't think that zoned out
junkie who slugs an Asian woman or
pushes her in front of the train you
know is up to speed on America China
relations or gets a newsletter from the
Council on Foreign Relations right the
reason why so many of this of the
anti-asian hate crimes Remains
unreported by the media is because it
doesn't fit that storyline right it
doesn't fit if you look at who's doing
it it's not the angry white trucker mad
that diseased bat soup gave him covid
it's minorities on the street that are
actually beating beating these Asian
women up and it's like that just goes
against that narrative of and also did
they talk about it then did any of them
did where was AOC remember we kept
asking are you going to comment yeah
especially in New York City no she never
did I mean her her constituents were
beating The Living Daylights out of poor
Asian women to Greg's Point
um but Mike Gallagher is going to chair
this committee how serious is he and you
know he has said that he doesn't want
people who just want a viral moment yeah
what was it about his approach that that
made him well it's interesting he had
bipartisan support for getting this
appointment and he's super serious about
it one of the things he plans to do is
he's going to call Disney's Bob Iger and
NBA with the silver what's it what's his
first name silver the first time David
um to come and testify because you know
about Disney you know bending over
backwards to make sure China's happy and
what that happened with the NBA you
mentioned NS Cantor freedom of course we
know a little bit about that story so
those are the types of hearings that you
never would have gotten without a
committee like this it's pretty
interesting and as to the what Presley
was saying I just think it's ridiculous
to suggest we can't distinguish
from the Chinese Communist party and
Asian Americans here at home the Chinese
Communist Party Unleashed a pandemic on
the world that killed millions and we
are still living with the consequences
of that to this day we also don't know
where billions of dollars of taxpayer
investment went so there's going to be
an investigation into that so I think
that the Chinese that the committee
that's going to look into China is going
to have a lot more bipartisan support
than probably other things on Capitol
Hill this year all right so how big of a
threat is China to business culture and
the world in terms of unleashing another
pandemic why would Ayanna Presley try
and minimize that when it is such a big
problem
for her being woke is more important
than being alive if Alana Presley was
president
we can only get tough with white
countries Russia the French who I'm kind
of itching for a fight with if if you're
Japan if you're China if you're the
cartels if you're a Muslim Nation you
know what bring it on we're just gonna
lay down because we don't want to offend
anybody do you remember that attitude
during the war on terror yeah you don't
want to get too tough with these Muslims
you know because islamophobia that is
the real threat so take away the trade
defense take away everything just as you
said um covet alone yep they unleash
this disease that murders a million
Americans and you're sitting in Congress
you're like you know what
I'd rather talk about infrastructure I I
don't know who her constituents are
um
I can't imagine they support that her
constituents died from covet 19. I think
their families might want to get tough
on China maybe and it might have been
America that was involved in that lab so
if you know she's America hater another
reason to look into it yeah I mean there
are so many questions China obviously
has a 50-year strategy for achieving
Global hegemony uh the United States we
have a different strategy based on who's
president but what the message they're
sending in Congress is we want to
protect ourselves as a nation we want to
have a policy about China that is not
necessarily a partisan I think that
while I am generally speaking
sympathetic to the squad I like AOC a
lot I like her her Verve her grit her
energy uh the problem is that they get
off on these tangents that are so silly
to to worry about people being
anti-china because of uh you know know
these these actions that they're taking
is ridiculous when you think China is
the Menace it's far more threatening to
the United States Russia is under 200
million China is a billion some hundred
millions I I think that China will
represent our future adversary for
Forever Until something awful happens
and I I got it doesn't
go down micro shrink it down now to
anti-asian sentiment in the city and and
in other places
with many Asian friends I can tell you
particularly the women are petrified uh
you know obviously a notorious case
brings it to the fore but they live in
the in a in a constant sense that there
is that they are different that they
will be singled out that that every
person of color that they walk past men
uh that is a Potential Threat to them
it's it's really very very sad what has
happened and I think that wokeness
doesn't help what should what the
approach should be is frankness
confronted inclusion real inclusion not
BS uh you know uh uh PR stuff like that
I wonder what her position is on the
Supreme Court case in regards to the
Asian American students from Harvard
that's a good question who are saying
that they've been discriminated against
I mean it may be the most discriminated
against group in higher education you
know arguably so the the data bears that
out and you know it's like that's not
even being politically correct can you
uh speak honestly to that and you
haven't heard a peep I wanna Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now